hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about how to perform a capsule stain
first what's a capsule certain strains
of bacteria and certain spring the
yeasts have this protective outer
covering called a capsule that helps to
protect them from the hosts immune
system so basically the immune system
has a hard time clearing the body of
certain strains of bacteria and each if
they can form that capsule around them
just that protective outer covering the
presence of the capsule increases the
pathogens pathogenicity what this means
is that if you have two different
strains of the same species of bacterium
and one strain can produce a capsule and
the other one can't the one that can
produce a capsule is much more dangerous
and can also require different types of
antibiotics so this means detecting
whether or not the pathogen produces
that capsule is an important diagnostic
tool it helps doctors decide the best
course of action to take for their
infected patients so in order to
diagnose does this particular strain
have a capsule or not you have to use
what we call a capsule scene now
capsules themselves don't absorb most
bags and so we use what's called a
negative stain where instead of staining
the actual bacteria or yeast cells or
actually staining the background instead
and so there's two possible procedures
here there's using a procedure that uses
only a negative stain we're just going
to stay in the background you've got
this dark background and then the cells
sort of stand out as these white these
white circles or rods or whatever the
shape of the bacterium may be you can
also use a combination of the negative
stain to stain the background and a
positive stain to stain the cell where
the capsule is unstained simply because
it doesn't sort of readily absorb most
guys and so you get this clear halo
effect so this right here is what we
call the the halo that shows us that as
a capsule there I'm even in the negative
stain it can be possible to see like an
outline of the cell and in some cases
and so you might still see that halo
effect now let's talk about what the two
procedures are in more detail if you're
using a negative stain only you'll add
the cells to a slide as a wet mount no
need to heat fix it add two or three
drops of a negative stain common ones
are neither Sun or India ink either one
will provide this really dark background
where the cells and their counsel will
azure stand out as white against this
dark background and you'll see that by
viewing under a microscope with an oil
immersion lens if you want to do the
procedure Reed has a negative and a
positive stain use you start out the
same way you prepare that wet mount no
keep fixing you allow it to air dry and
then you flood it first with one stain
for example crystal violet and then you
actually wash off the crystal violet
with 20% copper sulfate
so that crystal violet will stain the
cells the the copper sulfate has heard
the dual role of the colorizing sort of
making sure the capsule stands out is
that is that clear halo and also singing
with background and so you get sort of a
dark purple background and then sort of
like a little lighter purple usually
sell and that clear halo around which
you can see after you blot dry and then
view under an oil immersion lens if you
want to learn about some more stains for
example the endospore stain the Gram
stain the acid fast stain you can see my
videos on any of those if you want to
know a little bit more about what makes
a stay in a negative stain what makes it
a positive stain then check out my video
on the Civic versus basic stains in
microbiology and thanks for watching
biology professor